exit la bienveillance place à la méthode
pour choisir ses candidats aux
sénatoriales la république en marche a
même dû faire des malheureux selon les
propres mots de son chef de file dans le
département ainsi de stéphanie riocreux
sénatrice sortante ex ps ayant rejoint
heller em sur le tard trop tard
trajectoire politique trop peu lisible
souligne philippe chalumeau le parti
présidentiel a donc choisi martine
chaigneau qui elle a le profil
la conseillère départementale a pris le
bateau en marche suffisamment tôt pour
ne pas être soupçonné d' opportunisme
d'autres critères ont ensuite plaidé en
sa faveur
l'assise électorale notre tête de liste
et vice président du conseil
départemental réélue conseillère
départementale mer pendant 13 ans donc
on pense qu'à une très belle assise
électorale représentant la ruralité
on peut voit là un profil à profil
vraiment intéressant pour nous martine
chéniaux chef de file restait à lui
trouver des colistiers ils sont au
nombre de quatre des élus locaux chacun
issus de circonscriptions différentes
le numéro deux sur la liste le
conseiller municipal d'amboise et
conseiller départemental rémy leveaux a
une chance d'être élu ce sera beaucoup
plus difficile en revanche pour la
numéro 3 l'ex-élu de tours françoise
amiaud car le contexte politique s'est
tendue pour les maquereaux nist depuis
la présidentielle
nombre de maires également grands
électeurs ont été échaudés par la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation ou
la réduction du nombre de contrats aidés
mais martine chéniaux reste confiante
nous rencontrons une volonté de la part
des grands électeurs d'être
accompagnateurs des réformes
gouvernementales ce qu'il souhaite c'est
de la stabilité
beaucoup de confiance et je pense que
nous nous portons cette confiance est
sincèrement nous n'avons absolument pas
pour l'instant entendu de discours
dévastateur sur la politique menée
mais d'autres obstacles se dressent
également sur la route de la république
en marche
souvenez-vous des malheureux évincé de
l'investiture officielle
il préparerait une liste lrm dissidente
on pourrait y retrouver le maire de
chambray christian gatard et la
sénatrice stéphanie riocreux